I hope this works thanks very much I'm
very proud to be here but I proud
because of one and very specific reason
I was just told that this Hall was once
a church and now it's a kind of a
cultural home for talks concerts my God
this is what they were doing to churches
in the late 20s and early 30s under
Stalin no like you know turning them
into homes of culture where they had the
concerts and so on so it's nice to be
here in the truly bevic part of London
okay uh let me begin with uh ideology
today the book that I'm supposed to
present or rather somehow refer to
living in the end times is basically an
attempt
to practice again the old half forgotten
art part of critique of
ideology first through a couple of
examples I will simply try to convince
you that ideology is well kicking alive
and so on let me start with an example
which may even surprise you the two big
Oscar winners of the last year one
British one The King's Speech and the
other one the Black Swan I cannot
imagine almost a better example of
ideology let me begin with The King's
Speech the problem of the to be king the
cause of his
stuttering if you saw the movie is what
it's his inability to
assume his symbolic function to identify
with his title so I claim on the
contrary at the beginning of the film
The Future King is quite a normal
reasonable person he simply displays a
minimum of common sense like who can be
stupid enough to say oh my God it's my
divine right to be the king and so on
and so on and I read a movie as a very
sad tale of how to make this guy who
obviously has some intelligence stupid
enough to accept seriously that he is
the king you remember how it happens
towards the end of the
film uh the trainer the Australian
trainer sits on the king's chair the
Furious King asks him how dares he to do
this and the coach replies why not what
right do you have to sit on this chair
and not me the king shouts back because
I am a king by Divine Right to which the
coach just Nots with satisfaction I've
rendered him stupid enough now he takes
himself seriously and so on it's uh I
think seriously that the message is very
sad here it's you know we are all the
time from all sides we are informed how
we live in a crisis of authority male
patriarchal authority of course the
reactionary perception or rather
conservative of the crisis and the
lesson of the movie is precisely
although you men know that to take your
symbolic title father Master teacher k
think seriously it's a little bit stupid
but it's your duty to accept this
stupidity to become stupid enough to
play the role of authority now uh the uh
other film The Black Swan I claim I hope
you noticed it with Natalie Portman and
so on is even much worse it's truly a
kind of a anti-feminist
counterpart uh it I claim
resuscitates argu ably one of the most
reactionary myths about femininity while
in this same masculine universe that we
encounter in The King's Speech while a
man if you become stupid enough at least
can have it both you can have your title
Authority and still have a private life
let's call it it's an old anti-feminist
myth from old fairy tales to kovski
Kristof kow's film double life of
veronique namely this me that a woman
has to make a
choice your natural place is to withdraw
from from public
career to do your role in the family if
you choose your let's call it Mission
what you really care about as a career
you will pay the price for it by death I
think these are the coordinates of the
second film so you see that's where we
are in two popular films men become
stupid enough play your Authority women
don't play with career you will
die now uh let me now uh uh how now
let's make a step further through some
other examples from movies uh how can we
detect this
ideological background in popular
culture I think that the basic rule here
is to apply the
concept which was elaborated by
structural Linguistics of so-called
differentiality it doesn't only matter
what a thing is it only also matters as
its positive feature what a thing is not
it doesn't only matter what you say it
only also matters what you don't say
while saying what you say of what is
only implied in saying what you
say of course I hope you know that there
is a dialogue one of the best known
dialogues in Sherlock Holmes stories uh
this one is from Silver Blaze dialogue
short dialogue between detective Gregory
and Holmes himself which provides the
best example of
differentiality it's a short dialogue
exchange about so-called curious
incident of the dock in the ninth time
here is the dialogue is there any other
point to which you wish to draw my
attention asks detective Gregory
Sherlock Holmes to the Curious incident
of the dog in the nighttime the dog did
nothing in the nighttime that was the
Curious incident uh how does this work
in
ideology uh there is a wonderful joke in
Ernest luit Masterpiece ninochka the
hero visits a cafeteria and orders
coffee without cream and here is the
wonderful reply of the waiter sorry we
have run out of cream we only have milk
can I then bring you coffee without milk
I think it's absolutely a correct answer
it's not the same thing coffee without
cream or coffee without milk what you
don't get it's part of the identity of
what you do get in what sense because uh
if you bring this logic to its
extreme you can also see how a double
negation when you don't have just when
you do not have in this case coffee
without cream or milk the result is not
zero but what another my last example
from popular culture uh from I think
it's from early '90s you remember the
movie with Ian McGregor before he became
a Jedi when he was still playing uh uh
workingclass guys brasted off the hero
accompanies to her home after their date
a young pretty woman who at the entrance
to her flat tells him would you like to
come in for a coffee he answers there is
a problem I don't drink drink coffee she
retorts with a smile no problem I don't
have any what I like is that you know
what you get through this double
negation is
probably the most not vulgar but open
erotic invitation like that's my point I
invite you for a coffee then I negate
coffee and the result is not zero the
result is pure uh invitation why lose
time with such dialectical jokes because
I claim they allow us to grasp how
ideology functions to detect so-called
ideological distortions you should note
not only what is said but the complex
interplay between what is said and what
is not said which unsa is implied in
what is said do we get coffee without
cream or coffee without milk there is
even a direct political equivalent to
this joke about coffee without cream
without milk a friend an old president
from Poland told me uh in a well-known
joke from socialist Poland a customer
enters a store and asks you probably
don't have butter or do you the answer
sorry but we
are not the store which doesn't have
butter we are the store which doesn't
have toilet paper the one that doesn't
have butter is across the street and so
on okay but now let's take another a
little bit more more elaborate example
in today's Brazil they have carnivals
and as they like to put it people from
all classes dance together on the street
momentarily obliterating their race
class and so on differences but it is
obviously not the same if a jobless
worker delivers himself to free dance
forgetting his worries about how to feed
his family or if a rich Banker lets
himself go and feels good about being
one United with the people they are both
dancing on the same street but the
worker is dancing as it were without
milk while the banker is dancing without
cream you can also Imagine a brast of
dialogue between United States and
Europe in late 2002 when the invasion of
Iraq was being prepared the US saying to
Europe would you care to join us in the
attack on Iraq to find the weapons of
mass destruction Europe critical replied
but we have no facilities to search for
the weapons of mass destruction then
ramsfeld or some American guy answers no
problem there are no weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq I mean it was
exactly the same logic now uh now I now
let's put things in a little bit more
serious way why do we not see what
nonetheless in a way we see in ideology
how does IDE ology enact this
suspension uh I claim I'm sorry if you
know it already but it's crucial that
there is a a wonderful apocryphal
probably
anecdote from the first world war which
perfectly renders our predicament today
and how we see things that we see but we
don't see things that we also see it's
uh the anecdote about the exchange of
telegrams between German and Austrian
Army headquarters in the middle of the
first world war the Germans from Berlin
sent the message to Vienna here on our
part of the front the situation is
serious but not catastrophic to which of
course as you know the austrians replied
here the with us the situation is
catastrophic but not serious is this not
more and more the way many of us at
least in the developed World relate to
our global predicament we all know about
the impending catastrophe ecological
social and so on but we somehow cannot
take it seriously in
psychoanalysis this attitude is called a
fetishist split I know very well but but
what but I do not really believe it and
I think such a split is a clear
indication of the material force of
ideology which makes us refuse what we
see and know we can also call this the
mechanism of what Freud sometimes refers
to as isolering isolation where you
accept a fact but don't take it don't
you do not what you abstractly know you
do not
really put it at a symbolic or affective
level you do not really integrate
it you just rationally deal with it as
if this is the case but again you
somehow suspend its let's call it
symbolic efficiency this again I claim
is how ideology more and more functions
today ideology is not in in what you
know or you don't know you can know
quite a lot of things ideology
is resides in this underlying selection
where some things although you know them
you behave act as if you don't know them
uh let
me improvise a little bit here because I
think this ideological mechanism is
crucial uh this is what I call the
fetishist functioning of ideology the
old traditional functioning of ideology
was more symptomatic you know symptom
like Return of the
repressed you base your life on a lie
you repress ignore some traumatic truth
but as we say it whatever you do the
repressed will somehow
return in one or another symptomatic
form just to give you a stupid everyday
example the proverbial adolescent who is
traumatized by sex and in order to in
order to forget about it takes Refugee
in physics and Mathematics but then you
know sooner or later he tries to resolve
a a task like how much energy is
released when two bodies H hit each
other and so on and it's there but much
more interesting I claim is the
fetishist functioning which again is
operative today where you don't deny
anything you just a fetish
Ina a distance of not really accepting
it not really taking it seriously
incidentally as I developed also in this
last book living in the end times this I
think explains how why and how although
we most of us at least probably not only
believe scientists and in this sense
know very well that the situation is
potentially uh
catastrophic but like really are
convinced that this is the case but
nonetheless are not ready to do anything
again although we know there are threats
of catastrophes we cannot bring
ourselves to to act upon it to do it
here fetish enters what is fetish I will
repeat an old story of mine which is
very tragic it happened to a friend of
mine who was married and his wife died
young beautiful wife the usual story you
know she went to a doctor H breast
cancer in two months she was dead what
surprised us his friends is that this
same lady sorry this same guy after the
wife died
was absolutely ready all the time to
talk about the most painful moments of
the wife dying you know we didn't have
to play any of these games or don't
mention these in front of him it will
traumatize him no he was ready to talk
about everything so we doubted my God we
started to raise questions what's going
on with this guy like is did he love his
wife at all is he kind of a cruel
cynical subject or what then we learned
the secret every time that he was
talking about his dead wife and the most
painful moments of her death he was
playing with a hamster in his hands and
the hamster was obviously his fetish
this was also uh the preferred pet
animal of his wife so in a way playing
with the hamster meant I can talk about
it but hamster was the fetishist
standing for my wife is still alive I
don't accept she is dead now you will
say this is primitive pelo
analysis how do I know it unfortunately
I do know it because this hamster died
half a year later and immediately the
guy collapsed start for a week every
second day made the suicide attempt and
had to be
immediately hospitalized so again I
claim that from here you can see how
interesting is socially ideologically
the functioning of a fetish fetishist
are not idiots like you have your fetish
feet and see nothing else no fetishist
can be very brutal cynical
realistic they pretend that they accept
the life the way it is why because
secretly their fetish enables them to
acquire a distance not to as we put it
in traditional terms fully emotionally
assume what they rationally
know uh for example my thesis is that if
you look at modern top managers
especially in the United States one of
the model fetishes is uh what I
ironically call Western Buddhism this
kind of a vake spirituality
Transcendental Meditation whatsoever
that's their fetish they can play all
the dirty Market games but deep in
themselves they think oh I know this is
just the game of appearances the truth
is in my inner self and so on and so on
so again you know I claim that you
cannot really be a fully cynical subject
people who pretend to be brutally
cynical I don't have any ideal I know
life is just a brutal struggle and so on
I claim there always is a fetish the
question to ask them is okay okay okay
but where is your hamster or whatever
form this this
hamster this hamster has and this
hamster can also be I don't have time to
go into this direction but nonetheless
externalized like in the sense of you
should strictly distinguish
between your subjective beliefs in the
sense of what what you take seriously
what you believe
and I I will on purpose use this very
clamy
formulation and what you objectively
believe without knowing that you believe
it I claim that the basic lesson of
psychoanalysis today still actual fully
actual today is that it's exactly the
opposite one of the one usually
attributed to psychoanalysis that we
just pretend to believe beneath we are
hedonists with all the dirty obscene
desires and so on no on the contrary We
Believe much more than we know that we
believe like you you can
think I'm a totally cynical person I
don't care but in your acts there is a
belief embodied this category again is
absolutely crucial today today I claim
I'm sorry now if I repeat a short joke
which I repeated at least 20 times but
it's just the pure structure of this
Paradox you know nil Bor quantum physics
once was visited at a country in his at
his country house by a friend there he
had above the entrance Door a horseshoe
in Central Europe the superstitious item
signaling uh Destin that's the idea to
prevent evil spirits to enter the house
and the friend asks him why do have this
here are you stupid are you
superstitious and N Bor gave him a
perfect answer no I'm not stupid I'm a
scientist of course I don't believe in
it but I have it there because I was
told that it works even if you don't
believe in it that's ideology today we
don't believe in it we are all cnics but
actually we believe in it much
more